what do we got in the news neck anything
exciting going on this is kind of funny
chucky cheese because people didn't seem
to be wanting to order them on some of
the food delivery apps they changed
their branding nobody wanted crappy
pizza they changed their branding to
Pasquale's pizza and try and do we
handle urban market ahora
that Latino what does Pasquale's mean
Pasquale is actually a number another
member of chuck-e-cheeses rap band oh no
one knows I hate that I knew that
animatronic rapping I also love that you
you ever ollie then there's a purple one
and then the Ramos nonnamous though and
then there's the no his name is munch
munch when little people are if I'm
right people when you guys see like
better be munch characters do you guys
feel like there's like a like a sense of
like you it doesn't seem like you like
do you know what I'm talking about
Connor what like cuz you guys get like a
lot of the same attention I feel like as
like maybe Snow White at Disneyland or
like oh yeah oh dude like cuz alright
when you see characters like like
Pasquale ER like Chuck Chuckie yeah do
you feel like I said a Simba a symbiosis
with them like you feel like kinda well
they all get stared at but no it was
funny because like my job before I was a
comic as I worked at Disneyland cuz I
grew up in Southern California then
that's a great way for eyes great job
yes oh yeah please to me you're not
wrong is a really a homoerotic hotbed
down I don't know oh yeah all the time
with my guy friends yeah no idea they'd
probably graduates yeah no it was fun
cuz I got a lot I got a lot of attention
from the girls that work there because I
was like one of the only straight dudes
what'd you do work there alright
I I was not one of the seven that's now
okay I was a bodyguard for the
characters it's called being a character
host yeah you walk around with them yeah
and just like make sure no the Seven
Dwarfs are actually gigantic when they
in the costume yeah come out they're
huge they're not they should actually
hired Orff's and then make the costume
smaller yeah I should do yes mr. munch
I got it right yes ah the car I'm a
loser
carnation of the character is called
munches make-believe and it's his band
Chucky bandleader Helen Hannon mr. münch
Jasper gels and Pasquale II think if
you're gonna open a restaurant right a
restaurant arcade for children why pick
a rodent to be like the mat like that's
the number one thing you don't want in a
kitchen oh yeah I think like Chucky
Cheese yeah it's a mouse okay Maggie's
coz has a thing out for Chucky Cheese
would you admit that Nick is out for Joe
but Joe TMZ hates Chucky Cheese
everybody's Chuck and cheese who is it
my body does Oh your buddy man Jionni
Gianna
Chucky Cheese do I he tweeted something
about it was actually kind of funny he
posted something how he hated people who
were getting takeout from Chucky Cheese
before this actually happened one of his
friends the next day dropped some off at
his house and a couple hours later
Jionni tweeted Chucky Cheese is better
than in and out fight yeah well he drove
cheese he like filmed it with this phone
you know how like oh I skipped through
most leader [ __ ] out of it you know how
all young people like that so that's
what the new leg youtuber and tick tock
is like them ranting in their car yeah
like that with like quick edits for some
reason we're like just jumps from like
random like that's the whole video and
it's like them just like taking a hard
take on like pineapple he did like a
hard take on Howie like Chuckie Cheese
they should all be closed they're all
creepy the food is shitty and he did
like the whole thing but he did
definitely did it before all this yeah
they go after he's like a cheese all the
time there's always I remember they
found a piece of scalp and one of the
ball pits or something and that's what
said it all that's a big deal we used to
go on dates I remember people would do
like a mate like that I remember like if
your mom and somebody else's mom and it
had like a cute child or something they
would set you up on a little date at
Chuck E and the other table you'd sit at
one table to parents and the kids would
sit at another chair like a little
double date kind of I always like their
pizza I might get Pasquale's takeout
really I always thought it was good I
mean it's hard to screw up pizza in my
opinion maybe it's cuz I was eight I'm
not 34th birthday at Chuck E Cheese in
Baton Rouge Louisiana and I can only
invite five people why I that's the rule
that was like the amount we paid for in
the package
and were they a little alarmed that it
was 34 year old well the funny part was
it would be like if they had the
birthday tables it was like Hannah 6
Jonathan for Thea Hoch 34 yeah and then
the gig ban would come by
I loved it man you know uh so this is a
bit I do on stage so I'm gonna try to
not do it as it's a bit true story I
went to Legoland on my day off in Kansas
City mm-hmm and just me as I got I could
spend a day at Legoland I'll just check
it out it like I do Disneyland or
something I was gonna convince one of my
guy friends to come down and so I get
that parking line I felt too weird being
alone
Legoland psychology yeah darica sake
I'll just wait in the car together he
gets there I'm 30 I think I was 35 at
the time my buddy Derek's like 37 or
something so we meet we go to the front
gate and they wouldn't sell us tickets
to come to Chuckie to go to Legoland
really and I said what's why and they go
cuz you have to have like a kid with you
we don't have kids and like yeah but we
don't just let random men walk around
respect and I was according me they're
like we have adult night twice a month
and if you want to come to adult nights
like I'm not here for adult night I'd
I'm only in town this week I want to go
to Legoland Wow and they were like well
and I was like why are you doing this
and like well because we don't want you
know kidnappings weed you know we're
trying to prevent I was like well you're
gonna cause a kidnapping somebody go
steal a kid to get into Legoland well
also like would I be the best kidnapper
in the world like that he would be so
happy if I got it great that never takes
me the Lego interesting now drop me back
ever home no sex just fine yeah
now with a less green now would they let
two women go go into Legoland with
without a we should test it
I don't know cuz they were already late
weird it's a good point cuz like alright
because I've kind of a similar story I
was at a mall and I they got those I
think they're called busy bees it's like
it's like a Chuckie Cheese there's tubes
and ball pits and [ __ ] and I was in the
middle of the Midwest doing shows and
I'm by myself I'm like you know what
[ __ ] it I guess don't fit in those tubes
let's go let's go to busy bees so I so I
start walking in there and they got like
a an employee stops me and it goes like
hey do you have a you have a kid in
there and I go no I just want to go in
there and like I'm small enough to run
around the tubes ago yeah we can't we
can't let you do that I'm like you know
what in this case
probably a good idea just some single
white hand just walks and is like yeah I
want to go run around the kids does it
feel like a lodge way to the bathroom
shaved everything I'm a kid
yeah why you gone late for school
yeah you seen people yeah you mr. Thomas
has grandpa's favorite on it does it
feel a lot of times like you because of
your size and something you get to
relive your childhood in some instances
that look yes wow that's pretty cool
think about that that [ __ ] oh there's a
their mouth like a good one my favorite
ride is a Knott's Berry Farm Camp Snoopy
it's called huff and puff hmm and I
could still ride that ride my friends
can't oh we can't we're too big too big
look up huff and puff you'll see why
it's a train that you sit on oh cool and
then you like you can like move the
thing back and forth and then that
controls your speed of the Train oh yeah
they're gonna pay you to like be the guy
there it is there it is look at that I
can still do that dorable oh yeah it's
awesome there's Bobby Lee and his girl
good evening good afternoon and other
times thanks for watching that video you
just saw I mean it was okay but the next
video you can watch could be way better
what if you watch a video right now that
changes your life well you could watch
this one or watch this one watch this
one watch this one watch this one